- Jenna!
Do you, that's you.
- Hello, my name is Justine.
Wait.
- Oh, oh.
- I was, no.
- No.
What are, oh.
- My gosh, look at that gray hair.
- Oh my God, can I Sharpie your gray hair?
- Yeah, do you have one?
- Oh my God!
This is amazing!
- Are we gonna start the video?
- [iJustine] The video has
started, I need a Sharpie.
- What's good, everyone?
My name is iJustine
and this is my channel.
Today, we're gonna be doing an Ask iJ,
but apparently first, we're
gonna Sharpie my gray hair.
Because I am aging rapidly.
I did your intro.
Okay, just don't get
my, don't get my scalp.
Like you gotta just be gentle.
There's a couple.
- Are you not looking in the monitor?
- Oh, it's pink, oh, shoot.
(laughing)
I didn't--
- Can I do it?
- It's fine, I'm like 900 years old.
YouTube has aged me.
- I am so much older than you.
- Yeah, but like--
- Oh my God, it looks really nice!
- This is my accent color.
But I do wanna dye my hair dark.
- Yeah, just go get a nice little--
- Well, here's the thing.
Those little devilish
pieces still stick out.
- Yeah, oh my God!
- They like don't want--
Stop!
(laughs)
Oh my God, I know there's more!
Get out of here, get out of here!
- Should we start the actual video now?
I've got, I've got
written all over myself.
- Sure.
- Do we have an intro song?
♪ Hey hey, you can Ask iJ ♪
- Why do I still remember that from?
- 'Cause you can never forget it!
This is incredible because that
was like the first question
from David, what's your anti-aging secret?
You seriously look 20 your whole life.
- Oh, well, they're talking to you,
I look like I'm 7,000 years old.
- No, you're still tagged.
David said love you and he has a heart.
- He just hit reply all,
but you're sweet, David,
I forgive you.
- Hey David, you're sweet,
you're sweet.
- Thanks, David.
- When's your makeup line coming out?
I mean, probably should do one.
- Might as well.
- I feel like everybody's
doing their palettes and--
- I wanna do a mascara or a Chapstick.
- Mascara.
- I know Chapstick is a brand,
so I guess a lip balm.
- I would do a Chapstick as well.
I don't really like to wear makeup.
- Me either.
- Maybe a moisturizer would be nice.
- Oh!
- Oh.
- Maybe I'll make one with my hair dye.
It'll be a Sharpie, Sharpie tutorial.
I know what'd be cool, I did
wanna do like a lip gloss,
'cause I love Chapstick.
And I feel like every time I buy it,
it's, I don't know, I feel like it's,
maybe it's making my lips more dry
so that I keep using it.
I need a really good one.
So I should just make my own.
(slurp)
- Joey wants to know what
happened to the cooking videos.
And when can we have some
more behind the scenes videos.
(gasps)
- What do they want
behind the scenes, though?
- I think like making of videos.
- Oh!
- I think,
we'll have to do that, Tyler,
maybe some like BTS vids, you know,
like when we're like shootin',
we just can set up
another, another camera.
'Cause really, we need to just
have more content to edit.
So here's some behind the scenes
of Tyler getting behind the scenes.
Hold on a second here.
- Should I get behind the
scenes of behind the scenes?
- Yeah, I think we should.
- You probably should.
- Yeah.
- Well, here's our out of us ninja flips.
Got a camera.
I would like to do more cooking videos.
I just feel like when I was
doing the cooking videos,
there wasn't as much tech at the time,
so I would use the cooking videos
to kind of fill in the blanks
between the tech videos.
And then this last year,
it was just so much tech,
I was overwhelmed.
- The cooking videos are fun,
they're just very time consuming.
- Incredibly time consuming.
- But they are fun.
- From setup to editing, 'cause well,
a lot of times when we were
doing the baking stuff,
we would have to already bake that stuff
like the night before, so it's,
it was like a whole day
process leading up to it.
Evan wants to know if we
remember sharing the spaghetti.
I feel like that is
something that we've done.
- It sounds familiar.
- 'Cause I feel like we were going,
I wanna share the spaghetti,
or something really stupid like that.
Oh my God.
- Share the spaghetti!
(laughing)
We're sharing a plate of
chicken parmesan, which is here.
And they wouldn't give us another plate.
So, we share the spaghetti!
We share the spaghetti!
- Oh my gosh.
- We share the spaghetti!
(laughing)
We share the spaghetti!
- Stop.
- We share the spaghetti!
- Oh boy, I did not remember that at all.
Tamar wants to know what I
think about cryptocurrency.
- Eh.
- I think I lost
a lot of money.
- Well--
- The spaghetti, the
spaghetti, the spaghetti.
- We would have gotten a lot of money.
- Yeah, if we didn't--
- But we didn't,
we didn't cash out.
- I definitely have cryptocurrency,
but I am not act, I don't
like obsessively follow it.
If I did, I probably would
be doing a little bit better,
but at this point, I'm
just gonna hold on it, bye.
- Until someone's like, hey, man,
if they're in for a 20K, I'd be like--
- Yeah, cash out.
- Cool, cash out, bye!
- Spaghetti.
- Share the.
We wouldn't even have
to share the spaghetti,
we could get our own spaghetti!
We could open up a spaghetti factory.
- The problem was we got the spaghetti,
but they wouldn't give us a plate,
so we had to share the spaghetti!
- I understand, we could get two plates.
(gasps)
- Ronny wants to know if we're getting
the new Animal Crossing:
New Horizons edition Switch.
Oh, yes, it's beautiful, have you seen it?
- Yes, it's very nice.
- [iJustine] Oh my gosh!
- I don't know if I'm gonna
get the Switch, though.
- Well, I am, because I have a problem.
- You do.
- And I can at least say
that's a tax write-off
at the end of the year.
But you know what's great
about the tax write-off?
It's like, you still,
it doesn't really make
that big of a difference
'cause you're still
spending the money then you like--
- Yeah.
- No, I think you have
enough tax write-offs,
which I think I do as well.
I'm trying to be more responsible.
I have FOMO, which is why I end up
with half of the things that I do.
I don't need a MacBook Pro.
- It's a MacBook Pro.
- [Justine] It's a MacBook,
it's another MacBook Pro!
- Well, you know--
- I'm excited for the game. (claps)
- I think that I'm gonna have another sip.
- I was telling Tyler
about Animal Crossing.
We gotta get him on board.
- Have you never played
Animal Crossing ever?
- [Tyler] No.
- Oh my gosh, oh my goodness!
It is an incredible game.
Jared is saying, hey,
why haven't you checked out the Pixel 4?
(tapping)
Today, we're checking out
the Google Pixel 4 XL.
(electronic dance music)
I did check it out.
Joshua wants to know is the
Mac Pro versus iMac Pro,
maybe not an AMA question,
but would love to see a video.
Huh, that is, it's kind of interesting.
I mean, I feel like,
honestly, for what I'm doing,
probably wouldn't really be able to tell
that much of a difference because, I mean,
if I am editing 8K, you can
definitely tell on the iMac,
but most of the 4K stuff,
like, they both just,
they run like butter.
- Mm!
- Chris C Productions wants to know
what is the best and worst parts
of working with your sister.
- We--
- I don't know.
(laughing)
- We have fun.
- [Jenna] We do have fun!
- And also, we have like the same brain,
I feel like sometimes.
- Oh God, people are always like,
but you did the same thing as your sister,
and I'm like, honestly,
we filmed this completely separately,
I haven't even talked to her,
like, there's just one small brain
we seem to be sharing.
So a lot of our ideas, well,
we also have the same
interests and like hobbies,
so that's like--
- Yes, we do.
When we showed up to a shoot
and had the same brand new sweater.
- [Jenna] Same sweater, same sweater.
- [iJustine] Ready to go.
- Same sweater.
- Yeah.
- So it's fine.
What was the other question?
- The worst?
Probably having the same
interests and the same hobbies.
Stop copying your sister,
like, but I like it too!
(laughs)
I'm so itchy.
- Jenna's itchy.
I am also itchy, I think,
because you're itchy.
- Is it your right leg?
- Oh, that's my butt.
- Dude, right?
Oh, well.
(laughing)
- All right.
- That's a personal problem. (laughing)
- That's a different itch! (groans)
- Should we get you some cream?
- Oh, I think it's not
like that type of an itch.
It's just like this, I can't just--
- You have a personal rash.
- I, it's just like the,
it's more like my thigh!
(gasps)
(shrieks)
But look, right here!
- That's disgusting.
- It's my freaking side of my leg!
I just said my butt for effect.
David, I think I, how did
David ask me two questions?
But I don't know, it was a
good question, so I picked it
because I thought Jenna
would really love this.
The most stupid purchase of 2019.
- What I'm trying to think
if I bought anything stupid.
- You upgraded the Mac Pro
when I told you not to.
- Well--
- That was a year before.
- Well, but I also did this year.
- This year, yes, that
was worth the upgrade.
The previous year, I
said, don't do it, Jenna.
- I wanted the four terabytes.
I'm gonna take over, I
found some questions.
- I'm scared.
- Why Xbox over PlayStation?
I like Xbox, I like the controller,
I like my friends on Xbox.
I have a PlayStation, but it's just,
I don't know where the power cord is.
- Most of my friends on
Xbox, so that's really it.
And I like the controller better.
- Yeah.
- What did you just say?
I wasn't paying attention.
- I think similar, I actually
think it was very similar.
Okay.
- Ari wants to know what is
your favorite thing to do
when you are not making
videos and traveling?
Love to sleep.
- Eat.
- I also love jujitsu, I
like to put people to sleep!
- And I could elbow you right in the face,
but I'm not gonna!
Okay, what do you think of
the new Google Maps icon?
Questionable.
- I like it because I would
always get Google Maps
and Apple Maps confused,
and now I will not do that anymore.
- I understand.
Would you ever go back to
vlogging the daily life?
(groans)
- Absolutely not!
I would rather have all of
my fingernails ripped off.
- Okay, ooh, that would the next video,
ripping off Justine's fingernails!
(laughing)
That was cool, yeah, daily vlogging?
- It is just not fun.
It's not fun, it rips your soul out
because you live for the vlog!
- What are you most looking
forward to this year?
- Oh my gosh.
- Travel, I wanna travel.
Ooh, I really wanna get a dog.
- This year?
- Well, I want to.
But I'm also scared of commitment, so--
- But what about Mattie?
- I know, he could get
a brother or sister!
- [iJustine] He could
get a brother or sister!
- A little brother or sister--
- Probably a brother.
- I know,
I have to ask you about it 'cause we wish.
- We both will have
two dogs at this point.
We'll have to ask Mattie about it.
- We have to ask Mattie, he's
gonna go pick out the dog.
- Oh, I thought he was gonna
rip this other dog's
head off this morning,
I was like, Matthew, what are you doing?
Make sure you're screenshotting these.
- I'm not.
Okay, chill, your job is the most fun,
honestly, it's not that hard.
- No--
- For example,
you're lucky you don't
have to go to an office
and wake up at six AM every morning.
And get you paid like a
fourth every YouTuber.
- Well, I wake up at like
five AM almost every day.
- I'm kinda sayin' like,
most of these days,
we're workin' like 12
hours a day, you know?
- [iJustine] Maybe even longer.
Definitely not easier.
- I mean,
I just want you to know,
YouTube is not as easy
as some people think, so, that's fine.
(clapping)
Clap back.
- Jenna!
Jenna has clapped back.
- Anyway, that was just something I read.
Okay, what, we need
one more good question.
Okay.
- What?
- If you had to pick one camera
to use for a solid month,
what would the camera be?
- My phone.
- For everything?
- Yeah, it's easy, it's great.
- I would probably,
well, I have the A7-R3.
But if I was picking,
then I would have the A7-R4.
- Oh, she's picky!
- It's like, tell you what,
the buttons are crispy.
- The buttons are nice.
- A7-R4.
- The buttons really are nice.
I'm holding out for
whatever they release next.
'Cause I'm still hoping for an A7-S3.
All right, I think
that's end of the video.
♪ Everybody's got a question ♪
♪ On their mind (On their mind) ♪
♪ So now it's time (So now it's time) ♪
♪ To ask Justine (Justine) ♪
♪ Hey hey, you can ask iJ ♪
- This is a long video.
- You have 111 missed phone calls?
- No, those are just the voicemails.
- You have 111 voicemails?
- Yeah, why doesn't
anyone wanna talk to me?
If you see my missed calls,
like, don't even bother!
It's just--
- Oh my God.
- So basically, you guys
have to follow me on Twitter
'cause that's really the only way
that you can get a hold of me, so.
- That's harder.
- Slide into the DMs?
(laughs)
Oh, I don't know, what?
Okay.
- I'm not going to--
- Okay, let's just go, see you later.
- I know her secrets.
(shouts)
(warm electronic music)